مشاهدينا
تتابعون في هذه الصور مباشره اجواء
الاحتفال
بالقرب انطلاق بطوله كاس العالم هذه
الاجواء من كورنيش الدوحه اللعاب الناريه
تطلق في كورنيش الدوحه
وذلك مع قرب
انطلاق بطوله كاس العالم
في قطر
والتي يفترض ان تفتتح في الساعه الخامسه
مساء يوم غد
لتكون المباراه الاولى على ملعب البيت في
الساعه السابعه مساءا
اذا كورنيش الدوحه الذي خصص للمشاه
وللمشجعين
يتم افتتاحه الان عشيه انطلاق
واو كاس العالم قطر 20/220
[موسيقى]
يشار الى ان هذا الكورنيش تم تجديده
وتاهله وتخصيصه طوال شهر كامل
لمشجعين بطوله كاس العالم
وسيشهد العديد من الفعاليات
والاحتفالات المستمره طوال النهار
وطوال الليل كما هو معلن
في اطار الفعاليات المصاحبه
لمونديال قطر 20022
الدوحه تم تخصيص العديد من الاماكن
اماكن مهرجان
للمشجعين وقد قليل ايضا كان معنا مراسلنا
من درب الوسيل ايضا هذا المكان الذي
خصص كذلك
للمشجعين الذين يتوافدون الى الدوحه بكثره
وينتظر ان تصل اعدادهم الملايين
لمتابعه
المباريات
ضمن بطوله
كاس العالم وقد خصص رسائل نقل لاصال
المشجعين الى تلك الاماكن كان درب الاستاذ
او كورنيش الدوحه او
الى مهرجانات المشجعين
في اكثر من منطقه على امتداد
المناطق في قطر